and also with regard to what Hashem said
he said that Jesus never claimed to be
God but Jesus never actually claimed to
be a prophet he what there's no one
verse can hash him show anyone sentence
where Jesus said I am a prophet so if he
did not say that therefore we have to
then be assessed the criteria if someone
doesn't say something does that prove
that they are not what how do we assess
what they are right this might be
another David is not a prophet moment
you know be careful
no it's not because he's criteria was
did Jesus am so I'm saying if the
criteria is you have to explicitly say
something then we should use that same
level of understanding to say did Jesus
claim in those very words and say I am a
prophet okay if we show you that he is a
prophet then what well show it bring the
evidence and then you prove me wrong you
want the word prophet or you want the
actual concept clearly described unless
I said because what Christians try to do
we try to bring a concept Muslims say
for example set exactly like an odorous
I might be that where did Jesus say I am
God and I've had Hashem say that several
times so therefore if you know this is
the criteria then we have to then look
at where do you said I am a prophet how
she mentioned a verse in Mark chapter
six verse 4 yeah wherever a prophet is
not so I say again Hashem a prophet is
not from his hometown or something like
that
Luke chapter 4 yeah not an explicit
statement for example I'm just saying
that do you take so such a verse right
in mark and another verse in Luke in
chapter 14 verse 24 yes right in your
understanding okay yeah does that is
that Jesus that speaking it by himself
yeah in client no come there hold on is
he speaking by himself
yes he's implying that is so so for you
the word prophet or the Greek word
prophet s in conjunction with Jesus
Christ is suppose
by Jesus Christ himself with his own
words in the New Testament corpus but we
did for example if I said to you before
you say is no changes sports I could
argue I'm not as a leopard and this is
the argument Muslims bring because they
say well what is entirely subjective
would you respect because I write an
explicit statement is effective in so
much as the end user in this case
yourself or me are able to identify it
as explicit so for the reason why you
said look in mark chapter 6 verse 4 and
Luke chapter 4 verse 24 when Jesus says
that a prophet is not to be kicked out
of his own hometown and in Luke 2 4:24
says that whenever whenever a prophet
comes to a town he's always dispelled
from it yeah if that is in your
understanding referential to Jesus
Christ and in fact not just your
understanding of my understanding but
the understanding of I think almost all
the commentators that I've ever
commentated on this biblical passage
then for me I think suffice it for me
too for it for me to say that that's an
explicit statement that Jesus Christ was
speaking about himself in the third
person what you're confusing your eye I
think here you're confusing a
third-person reference with an implicit
one just because I speak about myself in
the third person it doesn't mean that
become implicit all of a sudden I can
speak about myself in the third person
but in very explicit terms so for
example if I speak to my children I say
your father will not tolerate this okay
I'm not speaking about anybody else
except for me unless of course you know
my children have some kind of chemistry
they don't so yeah the point on the
point I'll make it to Paperboy is that
the first thing you said very
confidently very stride that me I would
even go audaciously and
and I was waiting to see what you're
gonna come up with really and truly you
said get us one explicit statement
that's what you said you said give me
one explicit statement that Jesus Christ
says about himself every day is a
prophet and I'm giving you who you
accepted that that means that Jesus is
the Prophet and yet you're still you're
still not acknowledging the fact that
there's there's there's a world of
difference between Jesus calling himself
a prophet in the biblical discourse
which make it impossible for exegetes to
interpret otherwise verses Jesus
supposedly referring to himself in
divine terms which you haven't shown us
anything close to at mark chapter 6
verse when we see Jesus call himself the
Alpha and Omega a title for God how
should we interpret that I think we
should interpret that in the same light
as we interpret it with mulches Nick who
an animus lead seduced is not themselves
then we take that as an explicit
statement so I'm saying Melchizedek was
not spoken by Jesus that was written by
someone else jesus said I am the Alpha
and Omega so now what you've done here
is you've you've done exactly what
you've accused us of doing which is that
you said you set up a criterion okay
where in which all of the variables
don't line up with it so no what you
said the criterion is it's gotta be an
explicit statement by the way bring to
the pot every weekend we're done that's
exactly right so just to be clear my my
my position my position on the word
explicit and implicit yeah linguistic
perspective it's only explicit in so
much as its acknowledged as explicit
from from from the reader because if I
say to my father
don't yeah they'll they'll know how
explicit is right linguist can because
these words implicit and explicit may
completely desculpe the discussion what
you could be implicit in many context is
to me very explicit right so but what
the thing is we have no difference of
opinion here we both agree that mark
chapters number six verse number 4 and
Luke chapter number 4 verse number 24
where Jesus in no uncertain terms refers
to himself as a prophet is in fact
referential to Jesus being a prophet
therefore according to you and me yeah
according to you and me we say that
Jesus explicitly said a by himself James
our prophet whereas he did not do the
same thing okay he did not do the same
thing with him being God and now it's
for you to bring something as explicit
to me and you write as mark chapter
number six verse number four about Jesus
and if you do that then there's no
discussion anymore than we could both
agree otherwise I think you've shot
yourself in the foot would you respect
that paperboy you know why I be honest
with you right now yeah because you used
by audaciousness and all confidence in
Australian see you came on this platform
guns blazing saying you know what I mean
you said yeah it does give me one you
challenged us you challenged us you
challenged us brother
yeah you challenged us you came and you
said bring me one explicit statement
that says that Jesus is a prophet then
me and you say okay mark chapter 6 verse
4 Luke chapter 4 verse 24 says Jesus a
prophet now where are you going I want
to see you acknowledge that Jesus did
say which already did and now retract
and apologize yeah for the fact that you
you came so confidently all guns blazing
and you have no answer for me right now
my presence well you've seemed to hang
[Laughter]
Jesus while I remain who would have been
the best person to understood his words
and cultural references his mother in
Aramaic
all these weeks week of two-week you
come and you're acting like a hardened
man trying to pick on delay Muslim you
come on the Muslims show you give me one
verse that says Jesus was a prophet
we've got you two verses you acknowledge
that now tell me where's the same kind
of equivalent of us went being a good
god I love you Jesus called himself the
Alpha and Omega now president calls
himself the Alpha and Omega I think
we're done here I think he's right